three men arrested a website shutdown
and a player holdout why club
penguin for those of you who did not
have a cool childhood like myself club
penguin is a browser game released in
2005. after some success it got the
attention of a certain mouse they were
bought by disney in 2007 for 700 million
dollars but due to a declining user base
they got shut down 10 years later but
just as with anything on the internet
that gets axed fans brought that back
thus club penguin rewritten was born
unfortunately for those fans though
we're talking about disney
so on april 13th 2022 club penguin
rewritten was shut down the game was
dead but not only that the police are
involved the city of london police
stated that they have arrested three
people for allegedly distributing
materials infringing copyright but the
players were not deterred the website
was doomed but god damn it they stayed
on they held out for as long as they
could but it was for not